c'est avec cette radio que vous avez
envoyé le signal vous savez combien de
temps ça m'a pris pour faire ça h oh
j'en sais rien un peu moins de je dirais
j'en ai rien à sirer 3 mois en tout vous
savez combien de temps il aurait fallu à
quelqu'un comme vous
ou toute l'éternité e on a qu'à
contacter Palo pour qu'on vienne nous
chercher c'est pas aussi facile chéri il
va falloir attendre que le satellite de
communication soit bien positionné ça va
prendre combien de temps environ 2
semaines quoi ça veut dire qu'on va être
coincé ici pendant de semaines coincé
ici je trouve ça sympa survivre dans la
jungle ça a rien de sympa et que va
penser ta mère si on est coupé tout
pendant de semaines le temps que vous
reveniez elle se sera probablement
remariée
OK et alors c'est quoi le plan colonel
KFC tiens montrez-nous donc d'autres
babioles de votre invention qui nous
permettront de quitter cette île
rapidement quelqu'un a songer ce qui se
passera quand les de léard vont éclore
si vous avez peur des bestioles vous
n'auriez peut-être pas dû vous donner la
peine de venir ici Henry ouais après
tout c'est l'île mystérieuse il fallait
t'attendre à tomber sur des
Liv tu voulais trouver l' mystérieuse ça
y est mission accompl tu voulais rrouver
ta grand-mère elle est là mission
accompl demain s'en va